[Musique]
le vainqueur cours de danse thérapie
[Applaudissements]
ces collégiens de la procession emporte
le premier prix de cette 10e édition du
concours slam et danses urbaines émus
ces jeunes danseurs partage ce moment
avec beaucoup d'émotion
le dax à hawaï
près de 800 collégiens de toute l'île
avaient fait le déplacement pour
assister à cet événement organisé par le
conseil départemental des jeunes
ce concours laisse place à l'expression
artistique au travers des mots et de
l'expression corporelle le département
la vocation de découvrir c'est alors
qu'il passait à l'humiliation d'un autre
âge et et ses outils la lpm et azote de
nrj et aménagé sur scène aujourd'hui
oth off la vie et qui emblématiques de
l'art et nos esprits mal du tout celle
des jeunes qui s'expriment grâce au slam
sur des thèmes comme la préservation de
l'environnement l'histoire de la réunion
et la séparation la place on va
présenter
jauge de la réunion c'est le collège
adrien cadets qui remporte le premier
prix du slam
une journée de fête pour tous ces
collégiens un peu artiste qui le temps
de ce concours ont pu exprimer tout leur
talent
[Musique]